it's his son  his only son  [Music]  i need to know who's responsible i'll  kill my son  we've deployed large amounts of time  money and effort  in the search for justice not good  enough it's gotta be an inside job  you're gonna have to go undercover  there's an armed truck driver  we have a new edition may i introduce h  cash trucks can be dangerous  [Music]  who is this [ __ ] lunatic what  did you work for suck my [ __ ] dick  what did you say i said  we need a different approach to us it's  not any of the usual suspects  what do you want me to do i can do it in  two weeks  you only wish you could do in 20 years i  need a face  i need to understand what's useful  what serious i am  when i do bury grudge  if he's not a cop what is he  he's a dark [ __ ] spirit  you